in this video we're going to get some
more practice setting up systems of
equations not solving them but just
setting them up so we're told sanjay's
dog weighs 5 times as much as his cat
his dog is also 20 kilograms heavier
than his cat let c be the cat's weight
and let d be the dog's weight so pause
this video and see if you can set up a
system of equation two linear equations
with two unknowns that we could use to
solve for c and d but we don't have to
in this video
all right so let's do it together so
what i like to do is usually there's a
sentence or two that describes
each of the equations we want to set up
so this first one tells us sanjay's dog
weighs five times as much as his cat so
how much does his dog weigh so his dog
weighs d
so we know d is going to be equal to
five times as much as his cat weighs so
his cat weighs c so d is going to be
equal to five times as much as his cat
weighs so that's one linear equation
using d and z
and so what's another one
well then we are told his dog is also 20
kilograms heavier than his cat
so we could say that the dog is going to
be equal the dog's weight is going to be
equal to the cat's weight plus what plus
20 kilograms we're assuming everything's
in kilograms so i don't have to write
the units but there you have it i have
just set up two equations in two
unknowns two linear equations based on
the information given in this word
problem which we could then solve and i
encourage you to do so if you're so if
you're curious but sometimes the
difficult part is just to find
is to re-express the information that
you're given in a mathematical form but
as you see as you get practice it
becomes somewhat intuitive that what we
see in blue is just another way of
writing what we underline in blue and
what we see in yellow is just another
way of writing or expressing what we
underlined in yellow up there